et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Johanna Roland bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité vous êtes
mère socialiste de Nantes présidente de
France urbanne c'est l'association qui
regroupe les élus des grandes villes et
des métropoles et on va parler de vos
journées nationales qui ont lieu à
partir d'aujourd'hui à Reims on va voir
tout ça dans quelques instants on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Julien
l'Écuyer de la Voix du Nord bonjour
Julien bonjour Oriane bonjour madame
bonjour je le disais on va parler des
journées de France urbaine mais d'abord
un mot sur la réforme du moment c'est la
réforme des retraites puisque Elizabeth
borne recevait hier les présidents de
groupes parlementaires pour parler de ce
sujet est-ce que si le gouvernement met
en place cette réforme et encore plus
d'ici l'automne j'allais dire via le
budget de la Sécurité sociale vous
appellerez à la mobilisation
clairement je crois que le passage en
force tel qu'il
pourrait se dessiner et extrêmement
dangereux vraiment j'arrête sur la prise
de risque d'une crise sociale grave dans
le pays on est dans un moment où les
fractures sont là elles sont extrêmement
présentes ou un naturellement comme
femme de GO je suis attaché un système
par répartition un système durable un
système qui lutte contre les inégalités
quand vous voyez que les syndicats y
compris les plus réformistes disent
clairement qu'ils ne seront pas dans une
logique de négociation parce que le fond
et l'agenda choisi est extrêmement
problématique je crois vraiment que le
gouvernement doit entendre ce message
d'alerte de gens qui sont des gens en
situation de responsabilité qui ont
l'habitude de travailler dans l'intérêt
du pays mais qui l'a disent attention la
pente est extrêmement
je ne sais pas si c'est une provocation
mais en tout cas c'est
une difficulté à comprendre la
profondeur du pays
il a encore déconnecté en même temps
c'est un engagement de campagne de la
part d'Emmanuel Macron il a joué 4 sur
table dès la campagne présidentielle
tout à fait mais quand on regarde le
rapport du corps qui est sorti
objectivement il ne nous dit pas il y a
une urgence absolue à réformer le
système de retraitement et on peut pas
faire comme ça que les pensions vont
singulièrement baisser au fur et à
mesure des années et on ne peut pas
faire comme si on n'était pas dans un
contexte social ou pèse sur les ménages
les conséquences de la crise de
l'énergie les conséquences de
l'inflation moi clairement comme mère
c'est la première fois depuis 2014 qu'au
mois de septembre je reçois des
courriers notamment de maire de famille
plutôt de qu'on qualifie la classe
moyenne habituellement la petite classe
moyenne qui me disent et bien j'ai été
obligé de faire mes courses en deux fois
septembre une partie et le reste pour
octobre pour les fournitures d'achat de
mes enfants c'est ça la réalité d'une
partie des Français d'ailleurs lors du
Conseil national de la refondation avec
le respons ensemble de la Fondation Abbé
Pierre avec certaines organisations
syndicales on a dit au gouvernement
cette question sociale cette question de
la lutte contre les inégalités vous
devez la remettre à l'agenda du pays
elle est où aujourd'hui la question
sociale on dirait qu'elle est quasiment
disparue alors qu'elle est dans le
quotidien des Français de manière
extrêmement prégnante c'est justement
pas pardon je viens ce conseil national
de la refondation vous y avez participé
vous appeliez il y a quelques mois un
nouveau contrat entre l'État et les
collectivités est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
dites on y est donc aujourd'hui on a les
mots le Président nous a parlé d'un
changement d'état d'esprit nous a parlé
d'un changement de méthode nous à France
urbaine on est une association de maire
de grandes villes dans un état d'esprit
transpartisan constructif exigeant donc
on est prêt à jouer le dialogue encore
faut-il que les actes soient là et
reconnaissons que la suppression
unilatérale de la CV qui vient s'ajouter
aux difficultés des collectivités là
aussi avec la crise de l'énergie et
l'inflation
fait partie de ce qui ne va pas dans le
bon sens donc nous on dit un il doit y
avoir des concertations en amont pas
pour nous mais pour que ce soit efficace
pour les Français pendant la crise
sanitaire on a bien vu que s'il y avait
pas eu de collectivité locale j'aurais
pas eu le centre de vaccination on peut
pas oublier ça il faut quand même tirer
les enseignements de ce qui s'est passé
des enseignements est-ce que ça veut
dire une nouvelle étape de
décentralisation un nouveau souffle de
la décentralisation oui moi je le prends
profondément on a eu dans le dernier
quinquennat la loi dit 3DS vous savez la
loi portée par Jacqueline gros à France
urbaine on l'a plutôt soutenu en disant
c'est une loi technique en réalité qui a
amené des améliorations dans cet état
d'esprit constructif qui est le nom mais
on doit aller plus loin et sur la
décentralisation on propose nous on le
dira d'ailleurs journée nationale le
transfert des crédits de rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments 70% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre sont
dans les grandes villes on doit avoir
les levées d'action si on veut que la
France soit au rendez-vous du changement
de modèle ce qui dans le moment paraît
quand même complètement indispensable et
puis pour finir de répondre à votre
question je pense que cette
décentralisation elle doit aussi
s'accompagner d'une meilleure
territorialisation je rencontrais la
semaine dernière le ministre de la
Justice je le disais par exemple il y a
une question aujourd'hui d'indexation
des effectifs de la justice sur la
dynamique démographique si
l'augmentation de population notamment
dans nos grandes villes n'est pas prise
en compte forcément à un moment donné ça
pèse surtout quand on veut développer la
justice de proximité
est-ce que vous lui avez également
demandé plus de transparence je crois
dans la répartition les effectifs
qu'est-ce qui vous a dit c'est engagé à
ce qu'on puisse avoir un échange avec le
directeur général de l'administration
qui est en charge ces questions
d'affectation pour échanger transparence
critères suivis et territorialisation
donc on verra la suite on va revenir à
la question de l'énergie puisque ça
serait évidemment au menu de vos
journées nationales vous le disiez c'est
une inquiétude ça pèse aussi sur les
communes sur les collectivités les
grandes villes ne bénéficient pas du
bouclier tarifaire est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous en appelez à l'aide de l'État oui
gourmand aujourd'hui la facture des
grandes villes en moyenne parce qu'il y
a des disparités selon les villes selon
le moment où nous avons signé nos
contrats etc mais en moyenne c'est un
doublement de la facture
ce doublement de la facture il pèse chez
moi sur la question des transports en
commun c'est plus 20 à 25 millions vous
imaginez l'impact là encore c'est pas
dans l'intérêt des collectivités c'est
qu'on doit maintenir notre capacité
d'investissement et notre capacité de
service public certains de mes collègues
disent si effectivement il n'y a pas ce
qu'on appelle un bouclier d'urgence
énergétique alors le risque c'est le
retrait d'un certain nombre de services
publics et ça ce serait extrêmement
périlleux pas pour nous mais pour le
pays on ne demande pas à l'état de
prendre en charge ad vitam æternam j'ai
envie de dire la facture énergétique des
collectivités on assume nos
responsabilités mais on dit là il y a un
moment très particulier où ce bouclier
d'urgence va pouvoir s'appliquer et
est-ce que vous mettez en place aussi
des plans de sobriété on a vu à Paris on
pense à éteindre la Tour Eiffel
qu'est-ce que vous prévoyez sur Nantes
oui bien sûr à Nantes on le fait de
multiples manières on a par exemple
annoncé une baisse d'un degré dans les
piscines on a annoncé un renouvellement
de notre éclairage public en passant
totalement OLED ça fait une baisse de 50
% de la consommation l'ensemble des
grandes villes quasiment le fait Lille a
annoncé depuis début septembre avec
Martine Aubry l'arrêt de l'éclairage des
bâtiments municipaux Toulouse avec
Jean-Luc moudeng agit aussi sur
l'éclairage public il y a cette
mobilisation parce que notre sujet il
est double passer la crise bien sûr et
ça c'est l'impératif du moment mais pas
seulement on doit anticiper et
transformer le modèle vous m'interroger
sur non nous on a fait le choix de
développer fortement les réseaux de
chaleur et de s'appuyer sur les énergies
renouvelables on va continuer à avancer
sur ce sujet d'abord parce que ça fait
que la facture en moyenne elle est pas
de 900 euros mais de 600 euros donc en
termes de pouvoir d'achat c'est quand
même loin d'être neutre et qu'on doit
continuer à transformer nos modèles
transformer ce que je pourrais qualifier
de nos infrastructures si on veut être
au rendez-vous pas simplement
conjoncturel mais aussi structurel et
c'est également je pense la force des
grandes villes d'être capable d'être des
leviers majeurs de cette transformation
mais vous qui êtes à la tête d'une
majorité sociale écologique c'est ce que
vous dites est-ce que au vu de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui vous ne regrettez pas
d'avoir appelé à baisser la part de
nucléaire et du coup à ce manque
d'investissement affaiblit nos centrales
et fait qu'aujourd'hui on produit moins
d'électricité moi sur la question du mix
énergétique je pense je l'avais dit
d'ailleurs sur votre plateau il y a
quelques mois je n'ai pas changé de
point de vue qu'on doit pousser au
maximum les énergies redoublables on
sait bien qu'aujourd'hui on est obligé
dans la situation actuelle de garder
cette part de nucléaire ça ne doit pas
nous dédouaner de préparer l'avenir et
préparer l'avenir je le redis c'est
investir le renouvelable le faire de
manière forte parce que aujourd'hui il
faut arrêter de fermer des centrales on
va rester dans la gestion de la crise
une crise chasse l'autre à quel moment
on prépare l'avenir donc je pense que la
trajectoire doit il faut arrêter de
fermer des réacteurs ou pas je pense
qu'on ne peut pas en créer de nouveaux
je le dis puisqu'en Pays de la Loire on
a eu quelques débats sur ce sujet donc
oui
cela dit pour rester là-dessus pour vous
il n'est pas question de construire de
nouveaux réacteurs en France je pense
que ce débat est légitime qu'il doit
avoir lieu au Parlement je suis je suis
inquiète du fait que ce débat n'est pas
posé en même temps pour reprendre une
ancienne à la mode pour le gouvernement
que la question du développement du
renouvelable parce que tant qu'on ne
pose pas les deux je pense que la
perspective c'est posé exactement en ces
termes par le Président de la République
qui vient d'ailleurs quasiment chez vous
à Saint-Nazaire pour justement poser les
bases du projet de loi sur
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables et en même temps il
propose 6 nouveaux réacteurs aujourd'hui
à quel niveau on veut exactement mettre
le renouvelable dans le pays
on a besoin d'aller plus loin dans quel
renouvelable quelle territorialisation
de ce renouvelable quelle capacité
donner aux grandes collectivités pour
l'engager je pense qu'on est loin d'être
au bout du débat sur ce sujet oui alors
cela dit il est donc chez vous il doit
préciser le projet de loi d'accélération
des énergies renouvelables vous
concrètement qu'est-ce que vous attendez
de cette loi là est-ce qu'elle doit
est-ce qu'elle vous inquiète dans le
sens où elle risque de
d'entamer le débat démocratique parce
qu'elle souhaite accélérer les processus
d'instruction des dossiers comment vous
la percevez
d'abord je vais attendre d'en avoir la
totalité des des contours
je pense qu'il est sain que ce débat
soit posé
je pense qu'il est absolument essentiel
qu'on puisse s'en saisir moi j'attends
les objectifs chiffrés je le redis sur
le renouvelable j'attends de savoir
quelle est la part qui appartient à
l'État et qu'elle a la latitude qui va
être donné aux collectivités j'attends
de connaître les moyens financiers je
vous donne un exemple la première
ministre a annoncé un grand fond vert
pour les collectivités
un milliard cinq si on parle
d'infrastructures 1 milliard 5 / le
nombre de grandes collectivités dans le
pays on va vite voir que le compte n'y
est pas si on veut vraiment un
changement de modèle sur les
infrastructures c'est tous ces sujets
dont on va avoir besoin de débattre
autre question le gouvernement a levé le
flou sur le statut des locaux utilisés
par les acteurs des Dark Store vous
savez ces enseignes de livraison de
course
ultra rapide alors pour juste expliquer
des spectateurs il s'agit bien
d'entrepôt et donc de commerce mais
s'ils sont dotés d'un point de retrait
de colis est-ce que ça vous satisfait
que le gouvernement vous êtes entendu
sur la question des darkstore oui bien
sûr d'abord parce que
urbaine n'était mobilisée depuis de
nombreux mois sur le sujet que nous
avions alerté sur deux registres quel
modèle on veut pour nos villes et
quelles capacité de régulation donc le
fait que
l'alerte et la mobilisation qui est la
nôtre et été entendue notamment par
Olivier Klein avec lequel je m'étais
entretenu sur le sujet et qui a pris en
compte je crois qu'elle nous alertes il
faut le dire en revanche je l'évoque
quand même on reste attentif puisqu'on
nous a promis la parution du décret tout
prochainement donc nous allons être très
vigilant à ce que la traduction écrite
du décret soit bien conforme à ce qui a
été annoncé prudence et mère de sûreté
je ne suis pas si on peut parler de
sécurité
Nantes 6e ville de France n'est pas
épargné par la par la sécurité
quelles réponses vous pouvez apporter à
cette à cette grande question peut-être
d'abord
dire effectivement que Nantes et une
partie de l'ouest du pays pendant des
années ont plutôt été épargnés des
questions de sécurité on n'avait pas le
même niveau de questions que dans une
partie du reste du pays ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui tout le territoire est
touché c'est les retours que vous avez
dire que tout simplement le trafic de
drogue parce que c'est bien de cela dont
il s'agit en amont pardon de le lire
comme ça mais vu un marché qui existait
et décidé de s'en emparer avec des
conséquences évidemment extrêmement
problématique pour la sécurité des
personnes la réponse sur la question de
la grande délinquance du trafic de
drogue et du trafic d'armes qui s'y
accompagne vous le savez nous le savons
elle est du côté de la police judiciaire
des moyens lourds des services de l'État
en revanche nous on travaille une de ces
priorités d'une contractualisation entre
l'État et les collectivités à Nantes moi
je lui ai proposé ce que j'avais appelé
la règle du 1.1 quand la ville met un
policier municipal en plus l'État met un
policier national en plus donc je
recrute 70 policiers municipaux en plus
l'état recrute 70 policiers national et
en plus c'est une bataille nous
l'amenons avec une grande détermination
c'est des contrats qui ont été signés
avec plusieurs grandes villes d'ailleurs
les effectifs sont arrivés oui là il
faut le marché il y a pas eu de
d'entourloupe si je puis dire sur ce
sujet mais pour autant on doit continuer
à progresser et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'évoquais aussi tout à l'heure
la question de la justice parce que si
il manque un maillon dans le dispositif
et bien on n'est pas suffisamment à
l'échelle de la manière dont la nouvelle
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de la de l'Intérieur est-ce
que ça vous rassure les investissements
ils sont de plus de 100 milliards je
crois 15 milliards par mois je pense que
ces investissements sont tout à fait
nécessaires je pense que sont suffisant
il faut regarder près de 10 000
policiers gendarmes qui vont être mis
sur le terrain ils sont suffisants mais
je le redis si il n'y a pas une
activation du Maillon justice j'insiste
sur ce point alors il y a une partie de
la question qui n'est pas mais ça veut
dire plus de fermeté il y a trop de
laxisme aujourd'hui il y a moins de
moyens surtout regardez la situation de
l'aide juridictionnelle qu'on vous avez
un certain nombre de jeunes avocats qui
assument du directionnel et qui ne sont
même pas suivis de manière correcte bien
ce sont là aussi les plus pauvres et les
plus modestes qui en font les frais puis
ensuite il y a des choix stratégiques je
le dis quand même est-ce que on parlait
de service public est-ce qu'à un moment
donné dans ce pays on fait le choix de
redire il faut des commissariats de
police de proximité pour l'instant ça ne
fait pas partie des orientations que
j'ai observées on est dans un moment où
il y a besoin d'un service public
présent à l'écoute disponible et qui
incarne cette autorité républicaine dont
on a besoin de l'armanin dans le Journal
du Dimanche disait sur cette loi openie
qu'il allait créer 11 nouvelles unités
de force mobile et qu'il avait décidé
dans laissé à demeure dans les grandes
métropoles ça ça va dans le bon sens
pour vous ça fait ça va dans le bon sens
vous saluez vous avez vu ou pas encore
non ils sont pas encore arrivés puisque
ils sont annoncés en perspective de
l'organisation des grands événements
sportifs du pays il y a aussi ce lien
qui est fait mais ce qui concourt au
maintien d'une action de sûreté va
évidemment dans la bonne direction on va
parler politique et du monde c'est
socialiste puisque vous entendez des
voix s'élève à gauche dont celle de
Carole delgade Bernard Cazeneuve pour
alerter sur les orientations prises par
l'actuel direction du Parti socialiste
et notamment l'alliance au sein de la
nuit parce que vous faites partie de ces
voiles non moi je n'ai pas signé par
exemple le manifeste de Bernard
Cazeneuve pour qui j'ai un profond
respect l'homme d'État qu'il a été la
manière dont il a porté haut les valeurs
républicaines je me retrouve évidemment
dans un certain nombre de valeurs en
revanche il y a des choses qui me
manquent profondément je crois que ce
texte a été tellement animé d'une forme
d'opposition à la nupesse et à la France
insoumise disons le clairement qu'il en
a oublié pardon de citer le combat
contre le rassemblement national pour
moi c'est quand même un problème ce
texte dans sa dimension écologique ne me
paraît pas au rendez-vous des enjeux de
notre temps et puis il y a un manque qui
dans mon esprit important qui est celui
des quartiers politiques de la ville je
crois qu'on en parle trop peu
aujourd'hui je pense que dans un pays on
a eu tendance à opposer systématiquement
les territoires ruraux et les
territoires urbains plutôt que de
chercher les complémentarités sur votre
plateau vous parliez tout à l'heure des
enjeux désertification médicale elles
sont vraies dans nos campagnes il faut
les traiter Guillaume Garraud d'ailleurs
vous le savez travaille avec d'autres un
groupe transpartisan pour faire des
propositions sur ce sujet mais c'est
vrai aussi dans les grandes villes et
dans l'urbain donc l'absence de
référence à l'enjeu de la politique de
la ville et pour moi aussi une des
choses qui qui est-ce que ça vous
interroge ce débat qui qui monte porté
par un François Ruffin ou un Fabien
Roussel autour de cette gauche qui a
perdu un peu la boussole de certains
quartiers populaires de zone populaire
c'est au gauche des allocs qu'on oppose
à la gauche du travail comment vous
percevez ça je pense qu'il y a un enjeu
pour la gauche à renouer avec les
classes populaires oui je pense que
c'est un enjeu déterminant quel invite
dans ce qu'on a pu appeler la France
périphérique ou qu'elles habitent au
cœur de nos grands quartiers populaires
parce que ça a perdu aujourd'hui il a
perdu ses classes populaires ce lien
mais à l'échelle localement à l'évidence
et c'est vrai dans de nombreuses villes
c'est vrai à Nantes c'est vrai à Rennes
c'est vrai à Nancy c'est vrai à
Montpellier nous n'avons pas perdu ce
lien localement mais finalement ça fait
partie du travail qu'on a et je crois
qu'on a du pain sur la planche Olivier
fort aujourd'hui il emmène le PS vers la
bonne direction pour vous écoutez moi
j'ai soutenu l'accord avec l'anus et je
suis à l'aise sur ce registre pour deux
raisons d'abord parce qu'il y avait une
aspiration rassemblement très forte et
ensuite parce que la nupesse c'est une
coalition c'est pas une fusion moi je le
dis je suis socialiste je suis pas
vocation à devenir insoumise ni la
semaine ça entraîne la disparition du PS
si on effacement je ne crois pas non
Olivier forêt de porter une voix forte
dans cette couette à chaque fois qu'elle
n'est pas d'accord bah regardez le sujet
d'actualité sur les super profits
aujourd'hui il est bien à l'initiative
qu'Olivier fort se positionne dès
aujourd'hui pour un futur candidat à la
présidentielle qui serait commun aux
forces de gauche pour vous c'est une
bonne chose moi je crois que le
rassemblement de la gauche et des
écologistes est un impératif parce que
la nuit PSA globalement fonctionner d'un
point de vue électoral pour autant la
gauche n'a ni gagné les élections
présidentielles ni gagner les élections
législatives on doit pas le l'oublier
quand même donc oui je pense qu'on ne
peut pas attendre le dernier moment pour
se dire comment on propose un espoir
parce que le sujet c'est pas l'avenir du
PS des écol ou de je ne sais qui le
sujet c'est l'avenir des Français et de
ceux qui souffrent la question c'est
aussi celle de la cohérence
programmatique et de la cohérence
idéologique d'ailleurs s'il y a des
différences notables et notamment je
pense aux européennes ou prochaines
certains se prônent l'Alliance pour pour
les européennes mais en voulant marier
la carpe et le lapin
moi je pense qu'on doit assumer nos
lignes de différence sereinement
tranquillement ma position sur l'Europe
n'est pas celle aujourd'hui les
responsables politiques de la les filles
c'est clair et pour nous je le dis pour
moi-même mais aussi pour Mathieu Klein
pour Olivier Bianchi pour un certain
nombre de parleurs socialistes avec
lesquels nous travaillons cette
génération qui a à l'habitude
aujourd'hui d'essayer d'imaginer
l'avenir ensemble ça fait partie des
lignes sur lequel nous transigerons pas
jamais parce que derrière c'est la
question du projet européen c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai insisté tout à
l'heure sur le fait que c'est une
coalition dans une coalition on a des
points de convergence mais on a aussi
des points de divergence et moi je pense
qu'il faut les assumer fortement mais
aujourd'hui clairement il y a deux voies
au PS1 ISL porté par Olivier Faure qui
veut un accord avec la nuque et qui
l'assume et puis il y a une voix
d'opposants clairs à cet accord à la
nupestre qu'il faut pour vous une
troisième voie et est-ce qu'elle
pourrait être portée par an Hidalgo par
exemple dont vous dirigez la campagne
écoutez ça renvoie au sujet de débat à
venir du concret du Parti socialiste
d'abord moi je pense qu'un parti
politique il ne doit pas être
monolithique enfin le Parti socialiste
il a été fort à une époque où il y avait
des gens qui portaient des sensibilités
diverses il a été faible aussi pour les
mêmes raisons oui parce que quand ça
s'est transformé en écurie et c'est une
grande différence moi je pense que quand
les positions elles se font sur des
lignes de fond je dis même sur des
lignes de doctrine sur de la pensée sur
du contenu alors c'est sain pour le
débat politique quand ça se transforme
en querelles de chapelle en position en
ego alors ça devient délétère
contre-productif
non c'est pas ce que ce que je dis ce
que je dis c'est que c'est une bonne
chose quand il y a du débat sur le fond
donc moi je prendrai position et je
porterai ma voix avec d'autres dans le
débat je le dis aussi clairement je
soutiendrai là où on dira la justice
sociale et la justice écologique
aujourd'hui ça va de ça pour moi ce sera
un point important est-ce qu'on est au
rendez-vous de la transition écologique
et on n'est pas tous exactement sur la
même ligne sur ce sujet je soutiendrai
là où je l'ai dit tout à l'heure la
question des quartiers sera repérée je
soutiendrai aussi les démarches qui
diront oui la laïcité et l'universalisme
mais n'oublions jamais de le conjuguer
avec les luttes contre les
discriminations je pense que c'est
d'abord à partir d'une grille de lecture
sur le fond qu'on doit se positionner si
on veut petit à petit reconquérir le
coeur des Français dernière question
Julien oui sur une question d'actualité
Adrien catenin chez les filles Julien
Bayou chez eux élevé les affaires se
multiplient et s'exposent au grand jour
sur la sur les plateaux de télé est-ce
que c'est une bonne chose est-ce qu'il
faut en passer par là est-ce qu'on en
fait suffisamment au sein des parties
pour gérer cette question des violences
sexistes et sexuelles d'abord moi je
pense que sur le sujet des violences
sexistes et sexuelles il faut être
intraitable il faut être intransigeant
et je le dis
toutes ces affaires tout s'est
rebondissements ces commentaires des
tweets parfois totalement inappropriés
font du tort à toutes celles et tous
ceux dans de nombreuses organisations
politiques qui disent ce temps-là est
terminé sincèrement en tant que femme
voir qu'en 2022 on en est parfois encore
à minimiser ou relativiser des sujets de
cette nature ça ça me paraît
complètement inimaginable ensuite il y a
un vrai sujet c'est qu'est-ce qui est du
ressort de la justice qu'est-ce qui est
de ressort de nos formations politiques
nos formations politiques les unes et
les autres elles ont mis en place c'est
vrai pour le Parti socialiste des
processus des méthodes pour pouvoir
entendre la parole des femmes en
revanche moi je considère que cela ne
doit jamais se substituer au travail de
la justice chacun son rôle chacun sa
responsabilité là où on a une difficulté
c'est qu'on sait bien que la justice
dans un certain nombre de situations
peine encore à se saisir de ce sujet le
nombre de femmes victimes de viol
conjugale grave qui sont allés déposer
plainte sans que cette plainte n'ait été
suivie des faits on doit continuer
impérativement à Nantes j'ai ouvert un
centre de violence faite aux femmes qui
est ouvert 24 heures sur 24 je peux vous
dire que c'est sujet il reste absolument
premium merci Johanna Roland merci à
vous d'avoir été notre invité je
rappelle que les journées nationales de
France urbaine auront lieu aujourd'hui
et demain à REIMS merci beaucoup regardé
de la Voix du Nord qui va vous
intéresser j'en doute pas Johanna Roland
et l'éclairage public piscine les
collectivités à l'heure de la sobriété
c'est à la Une de La Voix du Nord merci
Julien merci joyeux anniversaire
[Musique]